ryan is
in roanoke hi ryan welcome to the show
hi dave how are you now better than i
deserve what's up
hey so i graduated this spring uh from
virginia tech
and i'm starting to take a look at
paying off my student loans and
i was introduced to some of your videos
through youtube and i'm trying to figure
out the best way to go about that
cool how much student loan debt do you
have ryan
uh just over fifty thousand i think like
fifty one
okay so do you have any other debt
besides that
um a car loan or
um a couple thousand let's go left okay
but it's
paying off quickly yeah yeah and is the
50 000 student loans is it broken up
into multiple loans or is it one large
student loan um it's multiple loans and
i guess that's kind of where the main
question lies
i've been saving up to try to take care
of the highest interest rate
uh one of those loans to save myself
some money
and after watching your videos about the
debt snowball i'm not sure if i should
do that or take care of a couple of the
smaller ones with
lower interest rates first yeah sorry
one last question how much do you have
saved
you said you've been saving to throw at
the at the highest interest rate or
you're just saying as you're getting
money that's what you're paying off
first
um saving to do that i
i still have a couple months or i guess
now only about a month until they
actually turn on
six months after oh yeah that's fair i
think my payments start
in uh in january what do you have in
your savings account
um right now 11 000 after an end of year
bonus i think probably more like 13.
okay and what is your smallest student
loan
uh 6700 i think
perfect okay so you probably heard this
on youtube we're going to list your
debts
smallest to largest right
so today i would pay off your car
and your smallest student loan
and you think that that would be the
best you know the best way i mean
i'm i'm definitely a saver i know rachel
talks about are you a saver or a spender
um i'm definitely a favor so i don't
think there's a problem to keep going
with it but you think that i should take
care of the smallest loan and
and the car first yeah because when you
look at the debt snowball versus the
debt
avalanche is another way of looking at
the highest interest rate uh what you're
doing
with the debt snowball not only have
studies come out to show that it is the
fastest way to get out of debt but what
ends up happening is you start knocking
out those smallest debts
and you eliminate it completely and what
you're not factoring in
is just the emotional toll and what
happens
to human behavior when you start to get
quick wins
and so by knocking off the small step
first you're actually
doing so much to keep you motivated and
ryan as a saver
you know putting we're going to tell you
if you have 13 000 saved off your bonus
putting it all towards debt except for a
thousand dollars is gonna make you feel
very uncomfortable
so just heads up on that too but that
gives you an urgency as well
so by paying off smallest to largest i'm
telling you the behavior change that
occurs in you
the motivation continues to get those
quick wins
absolutely now let's do a little math
okay fifty two thousand
fifty three thousand dollars minus
thirteen
is forty and you make what do you say if
it made fifty
yeah i can't remember i don't know if he
told us what his income was he
uh but so how quick you're going to play
off 40 uh
maximum of 18 months you're gonna do it
real fast now dude
get after it